stop
[Music]
the attack
food I was standing on the box it's so
strong not breakable they tied wires and
started electric shocks I remember
biting my tongue my eyes felt that
they're about to pop out I started
bleeding from under the mask then I fell
down
oh
[Music]
I was humiliated I was bitten by a dog
right here I was naked in the cell you
know there was no bed they meant to harm
us by bringing the dog into the cell
here is where the dog bit me
[Music]
it's a very clear-cut case of torture in
prison under the military occupation by
the US
[Music]
I think even after a thousand years our
great grandsons will receive our rights
even those who were tortured by the
Nazis by Stalin by Hitler now they're
getting their rights
[Music]